وقد اجرى رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
مباحثات مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتري
بلينكن في واشنطن وقالت الخارجيه القطريه
ان الطرفين استعرضا العلاقات الاستراتيجيه
بين البلدين وناقشا اخر تطورات الاوضاع في
قطاع غزه والاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
وضروره ايجاد حل عادل ودائم للقضيه
الفلسطينيه واستمرار دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه بشكل مستدام الى قطاع غزه
بالاضافه الى اخر المستجدات في المنطقه
وسبل خفض
التصعيد هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن ان قطر تقوم بدور مهم في
الوساطه واوضح انه ناقش مع الشيخ محمد بن
عبد الرحمن الثاني رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري الجهود المستمره لاطلاق
سراح الرهائن والتوصل الى هدنه
موسعه نحافظ على تركيزنا على هدفنا
الاساسي في المنطقه سواء فيما يتعلق
بالصراع في غزه او الجهود الاوسع لبناء
سلام دائم وتحقيق الامن اليوم التقيت
برئيس وزراء ووزير خارجيه قطر وناقشنا
الجهود الجاريه لاخراج الاسرى وتحقيق هدنه
ممتده ان هذا ضروري للغايه للوصول الى
الصيغه التي نتحدث عنها لوضع حد بشكل
مستدام لدوامه العنف التي شهدناها في
المنطقه جيلا بعد جيل والفرصه متوفره
لتحقيق ذلك وادماج اسرائيل في علاقات مع
جيرانها والحصول على ضمانات للمضي قدما في
طريق السلم والامن